la cuestión es que todas las personas
exitosas que conoces han fracasado antes
en lo que aman hacer yo no siempre he
sido exitoso en mi carrera simplemente
no lo sabías porque no era famoso en ese
entonces pero lo estaba intentando
estuve intentando conseguir un contrato
por seis años y me rechazaron muchas
veces todas las personas exitosas que
conoces y aunque parece que todos
simplemente se les da generalmente eso
fue precedido por mucho fracaso o al
menos una buena cantidad de fracaso pero
los grandes no son los que nunca
fracasan son los que aprenden de sus
fallos y siguen intentándolo
que son persistentes y tenaces para mí
yo intenté conseguir un contrato desde
el 98 a 2004 y me rechazaron todas las
disqueras grandes incluyendo con la que
tengo contrato ahora para mí eso
significa que cuando recibes uno tienes
que seguir adelante hasta que obtienes
el sí y creo que aplica el mismo
principio al aprender algo nuevo cuando
era más joven no sabía que uno podía
mejorar sus habilidades creo que estamos
muy acostumbrados
a la idea de que si eres talentoso en
algo está fijo la idea de que
simplemente es un buen cantante sabes
incluso para cantar he mejorado conforme
he crecido antes no cantaba de manera
correcta no respiraba bien hacía un
montón de cosas mal y me di cuenta de
que había una barrera que no podía
romper a menos que me pusiera a estudiar
y trabajara con un maestro para mejorar
y esta idea de que el talento es fijo ya
se ha demostrado que no es cierto puedes
mejorar en muchas cosas puedes crecer
incluso las personas que tienen talento
nato necesitan ir más allá de ese
talento básico que tienen y cultivarlo